[Music]
hey everyone how's it going today I have
a very special guest with me Shaun Allen
hey how's it going everybody
thank you so much for being on my
channel thanks for having me so for
those of you who don't know sean is a
iOS developer and content creator very
similar to kind of made or similar yeah
Sean you want to talk about what you do
and yeah so so my channel is mostly I do
a good mix of things that's what I like
about it right I do tutorials vlogs do
show called Swift news so if you're
interested in Swift and keeping up with
all the latest stuff that's going on
definitely check that out so a lot of
them might have noticed but we have a
Lego set here which I'm super excited
about cuz I've been wanting to build
Legos for a long time I'm gonna have
Sean a bunch of questions while we're
going to be building Lego stuff so I
asked on Twitter what we should build
and I heard spaceship coming through a
couple aside yeah a lot of people said
algorithms which confuse me yeah how we
gonna go with algorithms it's like oh I
don't know that would work so we decided
on a spaceship actually the
recommendation was the spaceship no like
Apple Park the circle building but that
just sends down there just a circle we
do have a special guest we haven't
introduced yet we do we are so
privileged to be here today with the one
and only Craig federighi
he is going to be judging if you a go
competition here care force want one
himself yes I want you to see so Craig
is gonna sit here I guess hey he's got
to be front room yeah he's judging the
building yeah so we're gonna we're both
gonna build our own interpretation of a
spaceship using only
what's in this box we're actually gonna
split the pieces in half and we can only
work with what we've got
oh I got the big greedy piece that's
this is what I really really wanna be oh
I saw this one oh wow I'm gonna
disadvantaged folks yeah all right this
new show of interviewing someone and
playing Legos is called interviewing
somebody in play Legos that one yeah oh
and before we get started we filmed a
video on his channel as well so be sure
to go check that out I will leave a
pinned comment and there will be a link
in the description box down below let's
get building alright Sean so first
question how did you get into iOS
filming because you have a very
interesting past yeah
so I moved out here to San Francisco
where we are currently in 2014 and I
have degrees in like finance and
economics and I was really interested in
like angel investing venture capital so
when I moved out here I moved out here
for that purpose to like star we're
gonna start ups maybe get on the ground
floor you know work my way up into that
world what happened though is the first
startup I worked at there's like five
people there and now I just found out
that I'm gonna do most of talking so you
have the advantage like you asked one
question away okay I see what's going on
but anyway no so I became friends of my
developers and just kind of like started
looking over their shoulder like what
are you building what is this tell me
about this stuff and started hearing
about it yeah I just started kind of
coding HTML CSS on the side on my own
out of necessity cuz I was like
marketing sales and growth and I was
building landing pages and we had like
two developers right so I don't want to
be like hey mister developer missus
developer can you build my silly little
static landing page you know they're
building the product so yeah so I just
built those and kind of caught the bug
like the coding bug right the magic of
like typing on your computer and then it
works on your screen basically kind of
quit that job and just went to a
bootcamp because I fell in love so much
and they were all they were all like
excited for me to leave because they
were all like developers - oh yeah go
get it yeah they were bummed to see me
go of course but they were excited to
see what I was doing yeah they were like
you're gonna become one of us one of us
yeah like shortly flying tires ever got
a job like about a month after the boot
camp and the bootcamp was taught in
Objective C this was like summer of 2015
so nobody you know Swift had just come
out or just been announced like you know
five months before which is also the
reason I went there gave me the push to
go to mobile development right cuz like
a perfect storm like I said I I decided
to development basically because of the
Swift announcement right now it's kind
of like talking to a lot of developers I
knew is like yeah everybody's gonna kind
of be a beginner right it's a great time
to get started yeah so that was kind of
what gave me the extra push to go yeah
but the boot camp was talking about the
last time I crashed I've been because my
first job out of there was Swift
and I've been focused on like nothing
but Swift ever since that's true you
you've gotten yeah I would say really
lucky in that like you've been super
immersed in Swift yeah this whole time
for like last four years I mean that's
what my channel is based off of that's
pretty much every job I've had has been
Swift and yes it's talking wrong by it
by going all in on Swift there's
absolutely some opportunities I've
missed out on right like because a lot
of the companies are still in
objective-c you know it's getting less
and less as time goes on so you know
back in 2016 like everything will still
objective-c
so I certainly miss out on opportunities
but I think it's coming is starting to
pay off now just being so immersed in
Swift for four years and now that like
almost everything's like Swift now yeah
and you have built such an amazing
community around Swift too with Swift
news and your channel talking about
Swift stuff pause real quick your
spaceship so far on my spaceship so far
are so different now we have any idea
though this juice like I'm building a
car more than a spaceship I actually
might take this apart and only work with
because I feel like now that I've
started building I know more what
direction I want to go towards what is
the kinda like software engineering
basically first and then you try it and
then you figure it out and once you
figure it out you're like alright time
to rewrite the whole thing yeah like
look at this like this thing is so
brittle just like software sometimes
we're like maybe there's like a bug or
something and you're so oh no well like
you said now you're like okay now I know
what to do that's what I always say is
like I always ask myself the question if
I could like start from scratch how much
differently would I do it yeah that
answer is like way different
be worth doing it from scratch right but
if it's like oh I'd only change one or
two small things then maybe I won't like
rewrite it yeah I always kind of asked
myself that's the kind of way you're
asking yourself like should I just
rebuild this whole thing so I want to
touch a little bit on something else
that I know about you which is that used
to be in the Navy for sure so kind of
what was that like and how did you go
from there to like getting your finance
degree and going to your boot camp yeah
so so the Navy was right out of high
school the interesting story about that
was that I knew at 18 I'm 37 now at 18 I
knew that I would have failed out of
college not because I'm stupid just
because I was like wait they don't care
if you go to class
right okay I would be like a social
butterfly like that that aspect of
college would have just consumed me and
luckily I was kind of smart enough at 18
to like realize that yes it was like I'm
this would be a waste of money if I go
there like I knew that so I started
exploring other options my father was in
the Navy so I asked him about that like
hey what's this what's this like because
I was just exploring other options yeah
he started telling me about it I was
like oh that sounds cool so I ended up
being on submarines out of Florida and
yeah that was pretty cool yeah and did
that for like four years this is like
2002 2004 yeah and then yeah got out
this is like a real quick you know life
story here yeah join the family business
which was Allstate Insurance and then at
like 28 or 27 all of those 27 have like
a quarter life crisis if you will that
sounds harsh but it wasn't but it was
just kind of like a maturing like I
didn't I was like I make I make decent
money but it was like I don't like what
I do like I go to work every day and
just like go through the motions like oh
this sucks
yeah so I kind of had that rich
maturation maturing how to talk
of like okay I need to find something
that I'm passionate about that I want to
go to work every day yeah I didn't know
what that was and I kind of thought
maybe angel investing venture capital
like I thought so that's why with the
school for finance and economics all
that stuff and now we pick up from so
I'm going back to school at like age 29
yeah so fun hanging out with a 18 year
old was that on the GI Bill yeah exactly
that's a great deal so if anybody out
there is in the military or was whatever
like I got paid like 40 grand a year to
go to school that's awesome like school
was free and a living allowance that
added up to get about 40 K years because
the
the little hack there is if you qualify
for any scholarships yeah your account
is like paid off a lot of people at my
college actually were on the GI Bill
over there they're a lot older than like
all of the other like 20 year olds yeah
yeah but they were awesome to like go to
school with because they really wanted
to be there and they really like wanted
to interesting that you pointed that out
because like yeah but no offense to any
18 year olds out there but you're
they're like I would have been in
college I wouldn't have cared about
school would have been there for the
social aspect but like when I was there
it was all business like I was taking 22
credits a semester going full-time over
the summer
like I knock out two degrees in three
years doing doing that stuff mainly
because also the GI Bill in the last
three years but also I was like I'm not
trying to be here forever right I mean
it was like it was like putting my life
on pause to go to school so let's get
through this like as fast as possible
sure and then yeah that leads into
coming out here and then yeah I'm trying
to get this piece out of this piece and
it's so hard I'm still stuck on this
propeller like I'm going to make it work
but there's no I think is there a
special piece that's what I'm saying I
think there's got to be so I know that
you just left full time content criminal
what you said and you're actually about
to move out of San Francisco right so I
did touch a little bit of bought this
because I really talked about it on my
channel about like living in Silicon
Valley I've shown a lot of y'all what
it's like and showing you footage of
what it's like but haven't really talked
about the experience of it so since
you're like actually moving out yeah I
want to ask you
living in Silicon Valley overrated or
underrated I think it is the best thing
a young developer can do so very not
overrated so I mean don't get me wrong
there are great tech communities in like
New York you know Denver Austin whatever
name it but it's not the same as being
here mm-hmm
I mean you go to like for example I do a
coffee every Wednesday with developers
and like name a big company there's
developers from that company code I'm
you know so she's like everybody's here
yeah and the networking you need to do
that being said that's why I made sure
to clarify that for young developer so
you not to be young but early in your
career
cuz you know you you get that Network
you get the experience maybe you'll get
the work at one of these big companies
but once you've done that or have that
like I already I always say I'm leaving
because like I've gotten what I needed
I'm Cisco right I've built my name built
the YouTube channel build a huge network
of developers and now I don't need to be
here anymore and then full-time content
creation which is the reason I'm leaving
is because I want to you know buy like a
two-bedroom place or two or
three-bedroom place that has like a
dedicated studio like it took us what
like 40 minutes to set all this up right
now so I wanted yeah I want a studio
that's just all perfectly set up and you
know buying a two three-bedroom place
here in San Francisco a couple million
laying around it's like legit actually
like two million dollars it is not even
joking yeah you have to do a chapter of
your career here yeah ever since I have
to but very beneficial to do a chapter
of your career whatever that is to you
that's true there is really no place
like Silicon Valley and I think I
actually are good with that like coming
here especially an early career where
you're just starting you're meeting a
lot of new people you're just learning
about what's out there I'm just feeling
the enthusiasm up for tech that's here
is really something special
that's that I've been here for like five
years and a little bit like texting to
get out yeah I am a little bit like I
need a little bit more like like
non-tech people around me nothing
against tech people but just like
there's other ways of living you know
without making a six-figure salary right
without needing to buy a 1 million
dollar home um that I think like there's
there's more to life yeah but when I
first moved here went to like all the
iOS meetups yeah I met all a bunch of
other like young early career tech
people who were super jazzed to be here
too and I definitely have like fostered
a lot of great friendships here too
yeah that reason so pretty the last part
or interview I wanted to do a very quick
like 5 question rapid-fire to you write
your opinion and read on some stuff yeah
I call it away this or that yes or no
part whatever I don't have names
apparently it's hard it is the hardest
thing a program okay and then we'll talk
about what we made um shot does having a
CS degree make you a better engineer no
yeah I don't but yeah I mean it's
undeniable you get the let me let me
clarify that with I don't think it's
required I think you can be a very good
engineer without it but I think it's
silly to say that it doesn't make you
better right having just that
foundational knowledge of course that's
gonna make you better
the thing is though is like if you are
past the age of college is like is it
worth the four years of opportunity cost
to get that degree I don't think so as
an adult right if you're already past
the age of college I don't think you
should go back to get the four-year
degree for yours a lot of time and again
the opportunity cost but if you're
younger and like going to school
absolutely it's the way to go
cool okay next question MacBook Pro
necessary for your first like entry into
software development or not
no when you say entry like doing it
seriously you're just learning just like
no just learning now this or that soft
skills or technical skills all right
this is a very Iowa specific one this or
that you I can't or city why I have to
go with UIKit only because there's a
meme right now that I hates with you I
oh yeah yeah is this about you I kid
because we're still two to three years
away from this with you I beam
yeah that's because adoption and lastly
mister that Johnny I've or Craig
federighi
I love zinnia actually I love them both
but my favorite thing about those
announcements I know this is this or
that I'm going off on a rant that's okay
I'm the guest
um I love the John Johnny I've like
videos like you know what I mean and we
haven't seen one in like two or three
years we really haven't I miss them yeah
so that's why all those rumors of him
mean like kind of like gone already
like four years I kind of believe just
because like we haven't really likes
we missed the aluminium body exactly
alright here's our final spaceship I
don't even say that actually we should
talk about our build so Sean would you
like to talk about your build yeah a
little bit
so I prioritize the wheels I make sure I
got these guys going and after that I
didn't I just had two basic wings and I
struggled against repel working but I
think I got oh that's how that what it
doesn't stick though I don't know so
anyway I got that working a little bit
yeah and then I just started stuffing
crap on there nice is this for
aerodynamics miss no I was hoping I'd
have something that I put on here I
didn't have that so this is an
unfinished build well Annie's refactored
everything is unfinished never done yeah
that was a last-second addition about
your little teeter totter yeah my TV I
watched this is like way better than my
first like my initial build it actually
looks like a real thing it kind of does
right
I don't know what it is but it looks
like a real I don't know he's very
symmetrical it is so I have mine is not
I have a little window box right here
for the people to be inside and look I
don't know what to do with these things
yeah I wanted to have windows I only had
two wheels but I was like well space
there's not that much gravity and on
Mars and the moon and stuff there's not
that much gravity so I figured that it
can just like balance and stuff what is
the percentage of gravity on the moon
like 40% 1/6 oh I was gonna I think I'm
like 90% sure of that I'm not a plumbers
not sure Mars I'm not sure if Mars might
be for you Mars is actually is Mars
do you have hep more gravity on Mars or
oh no it's less that's alright it's a
smaller planet you know who's gonna
correct us the comments yeah you're an
astronaut
yeah if you're Buzz Aldrin let us know
in the comments down below
speaking of let us know in the comments
who do you think won Craig federighi
thinks I won oh yeah I mean he has a
place to sail on you yeah we're you
doesn't even fit yeah I didn't account
for his glamorous hair yeah let us know
in the comments which one you like
better wash your clothes
thank you so much shopping is fun I
haven't played with Legos in a long time
me neither out of practice yeah this is
super fun I'm excited to have people do
play Legos yeah bye-bye you're by the
fifth Lego interview do I better see
some masterpieces oh yeah practice this
I have to buy a lot more Legos now yeah
this is pretty restrictive but it is oh
that was the whole point
yeah that's that's what my adsense money
is going on yeah but really though if
you'd like to see more interviews where
we build Legos and I interview people
then let me know in the comments down
below alright um I will leave everything
in the description box down below your
channel or your twitch channel this is
super fun uh and we'll see you next time
sigh